(audience cheers)
- What if, by the way,
what if every morning was like...
(Leslie laughs)
Oh, it is
- The pep talk? No, the
pep, yeah, I was like.
- Oh, inspiring.
- I know, I know.
(audience applauds)
So you moved, you moved to a farm
since the last time I saw you.
- Yes.
- Which I live on a ranch,
so I love that lifestyle.
Have you ever lived on a farm or?
- Man, I, that's my dream.
- [Kelly] It really?
- It's my dream.
- It was mine too, and I bought it.
- Something tells me,
(audience cheers)
something tells me,
when you have a dream, you make it happen.
- Oh, no.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
I want chickens.
I want a, I want a tractor.
I want a cob pipe.
I want a shotgun.
- [Ian] It's, I can...
- Yeah!
- I can get you all those things.
- I can too.
We're your people.
- And probably so can Amazon,
but it is, it's amazing as you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Just the interconnectivity of life,
as you know.
- [Leslie] Wait a minute,
that's a horse in your house?
- That's a goat.
That's a goat.
Is that a Nubian?
- [Ian] Oh yeah, there's our horse.
- Oh, that is a horse. I missed the horse.
I saw the goat.
(Ian claps)
- That's, that's my office.
(audience laughs)
- Your office.
You have a miniature, miniature...
- [Ian] Yeah.
- I love it.
- We were doing a, a
big board meeting for,
for Brothers Bond.
- Yeah.
Oh, for the bourbon?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- For the bourbon.
- A horse.
- And, and all, and Paul, Paul Wesley.
We were on this big
call with all the heads
of Brothers Bond, and all of a sudden
Delilah, the goat walks by and
Paul went, "Is that a goat?"
I said, "Yeah, yeah, it's Delilah.
She's usually in a diaper."
(audience laughs)
And then, then Lucky and then,
and then our mini horse walks by,
and everyone just stopped
and they went, "What is
going on in your house?"
But it's so special and for my, you know,
for our little one to be
able to live like that.
- Yeah.
- It makes for such a full life.